hello we'll be starting in more 10
minutes
rather
uh
seven minutes
so
thank you for waiting
i welcome you
hello everyone uh thank you for joining
today's webinar we'll be starting in
five minutes we are waiting for other
participants to join as well
thank you for joining and meanwhile we
begin with today's session
it would be nice if you could please
introduce yourself in the chat box and
let us know about your educational
background and your research and trust
a very warm good morning good afternoon
or good evening in whichever part of the
world you are
i would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on omixologic
bioinformatics and data science research
internship or the fellowship program
the research fellowship program has been
designed to help young researchers and
students take advantage of the
bioinformatics resources for analysis of
complex life science data and become
worst in bioinformatics
the research fellows participate in
cutting-edge bioinformatics research
which is led by expert mentors the
fellowship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mentor guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a bioinformatics project
the registration fees would cover the
cost of training mentorship and big data
t-byrinfo server and the platform is a
cloud-based analytical server which is
used by the research labs and
independent scientists around the world
today we will discuss about the research
specialization track the program
structure outcomes of the program and
take your queries and listen to our
research fellows project
we will also hear from two of our amity
research fellows mr hidey thakur and ms
akangsha singh about their research
project in oncology and neurosciences
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me introduce us we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy-to-use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
i would like to introduce myself i am
sonalika ray and i'm the omixlogic
community manager and i am responsible
for the interaction with thousands of
our users that are a part of our
bioinformatics community which is
managed by find biotech
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with a number
of organizations developing a training
program for research oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
the omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
the training has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and visual coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
the programs follow a project-based
learning approach which uses research
great tools to analyze data from top
peer-reviewed journals the training has
been completed by the participants in
the field of oncology infectious
diseases precision medicine
neurosciences data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omics data analysis
as a result we have acquired
professional certification to offer our
curriculum and support research projects
using our omixlogic project based
curriculum and together with our
existing modules for which we you will
gain access to the omnilogic learn
portal where you can try and explore
these modules exercise in pipeline
building coding and various methods of
analysis using project sources for
peer-reviewed publications
all right so now let's highlight some of
the current challenges and limitations
and how we at omixlogic help resolve
things with our training and research
services
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power the data sets that that are
analyzed are usually very large and they
take immense amounts of computing power
and memory that many personal computers
do not have
also despite being publicly available
data is usually complex to access and
coding knowledge is usually required to
do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists do not have
in a university setting students have
the opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but do not receive practical hands-on
experience with a full workflow due to
limitations mentioned previously
similarly faculty faces challenges with
being able to cover a diverse range of
topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general for example a professor whose
research focuses on oncogene expression
might not much know about metagenomics
of sea water
so to overcome these challenges the
army's logic platform was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systematize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologist or clinician
some problems for standardization
includes materials for these courses are
usually developed in-house taught
sporadically and are rarely updated
organization because the challenge is to
combine several different topics
together the flow and transitions are
needed to be developed and
systematization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or allow
someone to run forward
omixlogic uses standardized modules and
interactive sessions beginning with
mastering terminology and concept to
implementing these concepts with real
data sets in a project based approach so
what is the learning process in order to
create a clear path of skill development
omixlogic employs the bloom's taxonomy
levels of learning
this approach starts with the basics
where students recall facts and
terminology and are able to repeat and
memorize the material
with this space the learning builds to
conceptual knowledge
being able to understand concepts and
apply information to new students
the student will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods this leads
them to the highest level of learning
ability to design and create original
work also we will take you through the
program resources today and help you get
started with your training and research
journey
the research fellowship program will
also give you an access to the omixlogic
courses which includes courses on
bioinformatics precision medicine
multiomics including genomics
transcriptomics metal genomics and
epigenomics
data science that includes
bioinformatics using art and python an
example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work the users will
also be given directions to access the t
bioinfo platform for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of
transcriptomics data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and analysis cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
guidelines
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
so first of all now to proceed ahead
let's begin by signing up on the
omnilogic learn portal
and once you have signed up please make
sure that you have a complete profile
which will include a profile picture
full name with appropriate
capitalization
link to your social media handles that
includes facebook linkedin instagram
orchid and twitter and a brief bio about
yourself that will consist of
educational background and research
interest
the mentors can view your profile and
your progress under the activity tab the
courses you are currently completing
will appear under the courses tab and
finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under the certificate stack
so that was it that i wanted to tell you
about us what we do and how you can get
started with your research journey now
let's hear from our research fellows and
look what their research works were all
about
so i would like to invite mister rebecca
biotechnology and has just finished his
dissertation with us
and um
that's it about him i would now like to
pass on the stage to mr rider are you
here with us
[Music]
hello i'm audible
yes
uh let me give you the access
[Music]
all right can you share your screen
yes in just a minute
yes with the just a confirmation we can
see your screen
all right thank you uh is the first
slide visible where we have it yes
all right thank you so much
all right hello everyone hope you're
doing great
just a minute my laptop is
malfunctioning don't worry all right
fine
so
thank you sonalika for inviting me first
of all and uh to everyone who's present
in the meeting and who wants to
understand and know what we did here is
the presentation of the same
now uh first of all i would like to
share my experience key
what we did at pinewiretech was really
immensely meaningful to us because
we understood the entire analysis part
of
how you can really perform the analysis
on biological data
because it was something that is very
new to us but we still understood
in the given time frame of about six
months that we had for a dissertation it
speaks volumes about the organization
itself
so let's let's start with the
presentation
as you all can see on the screen my
presentation my topic was identification
of gene signatures associated with egfr
mutant cancers
and we had to understand the role of
vitamin d in their treatment right so
the two more important things in this is
that we took breast cancer first of all
and then we took the egfr mutant cancer
specifically and the third most
important thing is the role of vitamin d
in that
in in the treatment of breast cancer
all right so first of all we have to
understand that living in india
we have a very high prevalence of
deficiency of vitamin d in both males
and females now this can be attributed
to lifestyle changes this can be
attributed to
you know difference in
or very lack of
physical activity or the sunshine that
we get but still the end result is that
we have a very high prevalent
population of deficient vitamin d
or deficiency in vitamin d
now um this vitamin deficiency
was also seen in u.s
about in the 19th century or so
and
what they did there was a published
there was a publishing that happened
that
correlated
the
the deficiency in vitamin d with the
high prevalence of breast cancers
now this study was very interesting
because this is what we
had based our research on
and
the end result was of course of could be
anything from recommending or increasing
the recommended dietary alliance for
vitamin d
to actually finding out a noble
biomarker for vitamin d in breast cancer
all right moving ahead
now we have to understand the effects of
vitamin d and its effects on the body
but i'm sure this is the biology aspect
of it and it's a little bit
a little bit complex but
to understand is that
the breast cancer cells have vitamin d
receptors now when we say that breast
cancer cells has
vitamin d receptor that means that when
vitamin d is absorbed in the body
then it will be broken down into the in
the breast cancer cells as well so that
means that there can be a correlation in
the cell cycles in in the entire
metabolic range of vitamin d where it
can affect breast cancer so there's a
big big can that we wanted to figure out
and
understand whether it's useful for us or
not
all right this is the methodology that
we followed the first and the most
important part was selecting the data
sets
now i would say that this was the most
important and the most complex task that
we had to go through because one
it is tough to find data sets combining
both vitamin d and breast cancer because
first
what happens is that
there are not many publications that is
done
second is that
whatever publications we had or were
were found were very old or very new
consisting of very few sample size so
this was a very tough task but
raghavendranson really helped us in this
so finally when we found the data set
and we got the data set we had to
perform the analysis on it now before
that we had to clean the data we had to
analyze and understand some basic aspect
of the data series matrix
so
from that we did an explanatory analysis
and after that we did a differential
analysis on the data
finally what we did we understood the
data analysis that happened and from
that analysis we drew a conclusion that
is on point number three
is whether we can find common genes in
the data set and we can understand their
function or not
right so i will take you to the data set
right now all right
so in a crux what happened is that we
found two data sets that were very
appealing to us
uh there was one lung adenocarcinoma
data set
this lung adinocarcinoma was treated
with the normal treatment of cancer the
lung adenocarcinoma the osito nib
treatment that is given
and then we have the triple negative
breast cancer cell line that was treated
with
a normal treatment and secondary
a cofactor a dual inhibitor that is pha
767 491
now the common thing in both of them
that both of these were egfr resistant
so we had a common ground we had a
different treatment method
if the triple negative breast cancer
cells
had the same genes that were upregulated
differentially expressed in the lung
adenocarcinoma then we could say that we
have a result on our hands
also if it's not the same then we can
also conclude that the tissue matters
the tissue
anatomy or morphology matters in the
case of vitamin d and its effects on
cancer right so moving ahead
so this is the result now i'm sharing
with you
uh when the breast cancer was treated
with both
the treatment that is the laptop and pha
treatment that is dual cd7 cdk9
inhibitor these were the genes that were
differentially expressed right
and
to know more about this genes you can of
course search on google to know more
about these genes but these genes we
found really interesting so i have just
noted them down
for understanding
for example that mepc gene is a capping
enzyme right it produces a capping
enzyme
now
there are there are studies which tell
us that mepc depletion affects the
expression of cancer relevant cases
now hence it is important for us to
understand the role of this mvpc gene
second was caspase caspase 7 again is a
very common gene that is found now in
some studies again it is said that it is
aberrantly expressed in breast cancer
cases and it can cause cell growth and
proliferation
and down regulation of a protein that
cast heaven positive breast cancers
could be one of the potential
therapeutic strategies so decreasing the
amount of cash based seven can really
help us in understanding or curing
breast cancer
the next is
sn1 p1g that is mad nuclear interacting
protein again it is a very very common
pro very very common gene
but this gene was important in breast
cancer and again we can say that lung
metastasis of breast cancer
hence we took out this gene specifically
moving ahead
for the lung adenocarcinoma data set
these are the three volcano plots we
found now you have to understand why
three is because
we had to study the effect of
only the drug only vitamin d and when
both like vitamin d and the drug were
given
so this is only uh this is only vitamin
d this is only the drug and this is both
drug and vitamin d as you can see both
of these genes are overly expressed or
differentially expressed in the third
one right
so this is what we needed this is what
we wanted the cyb24a1 gene is something
that we could positively look at in
terms of effect of vitamin d on breast
cancer and
although it's a very less result to be
found or a very uh
but but it is something so we're happy
that we finally got something of
interest
so what we have to understand is that
cybe 24 avenging is a very common gene
right because it is found in the
cytochrome p40 system in the liver
but this is present wherever vitamin d
breakdown needs to be taken place
so what we concluded is that
whenever there is an increase in the
level of cyp24a1 gene there is a
potential that it can be used as a
biomarker especially in
predicting prognosis
so predicting and prognosis purpose it
can be used so this was something that
we proposed in the result key
yes if this gene is overly expressed in
vitamin d cases
then it could be used as a predicting
biomarker for
breast cancer
the only thing that needs to be done is
in the next slide what we can do right
so we found that vitamin d
supplementation can really elevate
inhibitor resistance as seen in the
breast cancer treatment we found that
it it is happening now we also found
that the vitamin d treatment needs to be
further investigated for other cancer
subtypes and other cancers as well
and if vitamin d can assist the
individuals with breast cancer to
control the same symptoms and live
longer you have to understand what you
will have in your hands if this study is
proven
it's like a david and a goliath story
where
a simple molecule has vitamin d
if proven can fight breast cancer then
you are fighting the entire pharma lobby
because they are using
millions of dollars of drugs to fight
these cancers and
you will be putting a dent on their
profits big time so if this study
anybody who wants to take up this study
can prove that vitamin d can really
affect the treatment of breast cancer
and can help in treatment of any cancer
for that matter
i'm i'm saying really really can prove
then they have a huge fight on their
hands and if you really want to watch
the fight i suggest you watch this movie
called concussion on netflix
just out of interest all right so moving
on the furthest studies that can be done
in this prospect are
there's a vertical possibility of
studying this because
you can look deeper into the effects of
genes on breast cancer so vitamin d
effects of other genes of breast cancer
you can do that secondly what you can do
is horizontally you can study different
cancers and effects of vitamin d and if
there's a correlation then you can
put that correlation in that yes there
are different cancers which have similar
effect when they are treated with
vitamin d so this can also be a very
good topic to understand
so finally this is
because i was presenting this for my
college university as well uh my
university as well so i had some
articles that told us the effect of
vitamin d on cancer these are pretty
recent studies that are done
so as you can see that people are going
in this direction that there are
therapeutic benefits
uh with different types of cancer you
have leukemia here you have different
cancers colorectal cancer as well so
people are going in this direction to
understand that vitamin d can
really be a miracle molecule for helping
out and fighting cancer
and with that thank you everyone
let's use the science and
let's use what we have learned and the
knowledge to cure the world because
i will finally just say this key
there should be a usage to what you
learned in classes
it's it's important to yes study but
it's more important to apply that study
somewhere so we gave you a direction in
this that yes vitamin d can really help
us fight cancer but it is up to you to
take up this fight further and
finally prove to this world that yes
it's a miracle molecule and it can be
used
yes or no or whatever the results might
be but you have to take this fight to
help out the people who are fighting
this
menace in this world so that's it over
to somalia thank you so much everyone
thank you so much that was a wonderful
presentation i really like the way you
presented your research
and uh
yes exactly so we explained and
uh how you have put together all your
results together and now i would like to
hear from dr raghav what does he think
about your project and how further you
can improve maybe if there is any scope
oh do you talk to raghav
thank you sonalika and thank you today
that was
that was very well presented and very uh
it has the overtones of a lot of popular
lectures and
and
thank you for taking the research
beyond answering a scientific questions
point of view
thank you so much
so
much
sometimes for most of the times when uh
when we are working or uh when we are
focusing on on a scientific query
um
the implications and the real world
applications and the and the enormous
potential of that
might not be our focus and we might be
too focused on the this expression at
hand
so we are all working or using science
for the betterment of the world and
thank you for putting that
wonderful message forward thank you for
that
thank you so much sir thank you so much
thank you so much for allowing as well
if anyone has any questions
they can put post in the chat box and
you can reach out to me on linkedin as
well and yes thank you everyone for
patiently listening
over to youtube
thank you
[Music]
thank you dr raghav anand wants to ask
something and then you can unmute
yourself
uh hello ma'am and first of all good
evening to all one and all who is here
in this meeting actually i have joined
late in this meeting but uh i'm sorry
extremely sorry for that because i am
missing
conclusions and all that
but my question is to you uh like how as
a i'm individual like i'm working as a
like intern in csi lab but i want to
also contribute in this project as well
so could you please tell me as a student
of biotechnology how i can contribute to
this project and how it is going to help
dr raghav would you like to take that
question
yes sure can you please one more time
repeat as a biotechnology student
uh yes sure sure so actually i am a
biotechnologist friend right now i'm
personally beating biotechnology i'm
right on fourth year so can you please
tell me how i can be a part of this
project and what you are right now
talking and how it can contribute to the
world as well as to me as well for my
development in my career
as well
sure i mean
if you're not mistaken
biological research is not what it used
to be like like something like 20 or 15
years ago
15 years ago then you will you will have
actually identified some specific
questions to answer and then formulate
your hypothesis or
questions based on some initial data set
or initial understanding of a system and
then you design an experiment collect
data analyze data publish the results or
find themselves
but what where bioinformatics can help
in this aspect is due to the
availability of an enormous amount of
data
it can help you make some important
predictions or important
suggestions and help you make some
critical
decisions based on whatever data that is
available like um you might want to
focus on a species and a very closely
related species might have been
investigated it in a greater detail so
you can look at that specific
publication and that specific data and
design your um
your experiments and and try to
understand your question from from that
information so this these are the ways
in which you can employ bioinformatics
as a
supportive
science for
maine
or your
research in focus which could be based
purely on biotechnological uh protocols
but bioinformatics as such as what we
are trying to do is we are trying to use
our leverage publicly available data
and trying to understand the pattern
that is available in not one not two but
many more of these data available and
trying to make some conclusions for the
um
biological question that we are trying
to address or for the research area that
we are trying to focus as you also know
there is enormous amount of data that is
available so we are
our science depends on this availability
of data and good quality data and
most of the time
we will actually spend very careful
amount of time in picking the right data
that will help us understand the
question so if you are interested in
expanding your horizons beyond your lab
environment like
using bioinformatics methods to aid your
research or you can use bioinformatics
methods to completely focus on the
problem from the different dimensions
right you don't have to generate any
data but you can use whatever data
available
to find some important and critical
results and implications and inferences
from your data so these are the ways in
which you can make use of the research
fellowship program to help yourself so
in a nutshell you can either
learn the nuts and bolts of all the
analysis methods and the different
comparisons of these vessels and
different comparisons of the sequence of
these analysis methods from for
different omics data type so that you
can expand your horizons um from or
expand your skill sets or you can take
part of your long term project and do a
bioinformatics based analysis on that
specific part so that it helps you in
the long term future so this it depends
on what you want to know what you want
to do and we will help you in in
actually finalizing and in understanding
what you are clearly interested in so we
will take it from there and give you
pointers in trying to
show you directions in which way you can
go to
achieve what you are trying to
understand or what you are trying to
investigate okay
uh yes sir i understood
i will i will then pass the stage back
to sunalika
yes thank you so much and are there any
more questions
you can feel free to please and mute
yourself and take it up
all right so if there are no more
questions uh we would now like to
address uh a question on our behalf that
we usually get asked that's about video
specialization tracks so what are the
different specialization tracks or what
are the different data analysis types
that a researcher can work on and before
working in a specific field with us you
need to get yourself trained so what are
these fields or types of data analysis
courses that you can take and learn from
and then get started with your research
project so for that we have a video
recorded by mentor dr raghav indran and
i would now like to request ojaspee to
be share a screen and play that video
after the video recording is over
uh the the participants can unmute
themselves and take their questions dr
raghav is here with us he will answer
them
thank you so much oh jason can you yeah
okay thank you
so this is a consolidated
web page for what the research
topics and what the research fellowship
inter program is all about
so when we go down i think you would
have gotten a lot of introduction about
how different students and researchers
can make use of big data while
performing different analysis and what
do i mean by that let's go down you will
get
these
specific advantages of
when you sign up for the research
fellowship program so you have
curriculum that specifically designed
for the for your research area and for
your research interests and you have
your own self-paced learning and
most of the courses and most of the
resources that we are going to share
with you in the research fellowship
program is asynchronous meaning you will
learn at your pace you will do this at
your pace and then
we will be there to discuss with you
about your progress and
about how to proceed further in the
research fellowship program and you will
get hands-on with big data as expertly
demonstrated by three students
research topic so all of them
obtain data from publicly available
forum and all of these data are big data
big omics data and they used this big
comics data to address different parts
of the biological
queries and questions and you will have
access to expert mentors like myself
like dr mohit and others so when you
start learning you will get
immediate feedback from us and we are
accessible to you offline and also uh we
we will meet you uh once or twice during
the week uh during the scheduled uh
research fellowship meeting and also if
you request for one-on-one meeting for
some specific cases then we will offer
that also
so when you go down what are the
different areas in which the omix data
and multi-omics data in general are
being used to address specific research
questions you have a variety of topics
that uses omics data as of now which
will include genomics data
transcriptomics data epigenomics
metagenomics and these are only few that
we are targeting or that we are actually
focusing on you have
furthermore you have proteomics you have
metabolomics and etc a lot of other
omics data types are coming up in trying
to address different areas of biological
research so and
we have actually this site this web link
gives you one of the some of the major
applications of our mix data analysis to
different areas of analysis that is
described that is focused so some of the
obvious focus is on infectious diseases
and the pandemic era that we are
currently living is is a perfect example
for what omics data can achieve in
in addressing infectious diseases case
and we all
know uh different terminologies related
to source like variance of concern
variance of interest how does it spread
like
what are the different lineages right
and
what are the mutations that actually
characterize variance of concern these
variants of interest and all of these
analysis are direct results from
genomics data and transcriptomic data
analysis so when you use the whole
genome sequence of the virus and try to
compare it with the
other strains and other variants of this
same virus you will get lot of
information and this is just one example
of what you can achieve from
from the from sequencing the whole
genome sequence of the virus and
similarly this can be extended to a
transcript of landscape analysis which
will characterize how a patient is going
to respond to the onset of the disease
or to some
drugs that is going to fight against the
progression of this disease and these
are just two omics data types that is
trying to provide us with lot of
information in addressing some of the
key questions in infectious disuses and
we can again do this in meta genomics
data analysis and epigenomics data
analysis which are also extremely uh
important omics data type that are
coming up and i would like to stress the
importance of meta genomics data
analysis where the gut microbiome or the
microbiome
estimation of the human gut is being
linked to various other disease onsets
like cancer like allergy like even
neurological disorders and pathological
states so so that
that level of
association is
is been
exploration of that level of association
has been carried out at various
different uh labs and and this is one of
the
interesting and upcoming omics data
types analysis methods and the questions
that we can answer through
analyzing and observing patterns within
the metagenomics data so when you go
down we have lot of project examples on
omix
learn which focuses on different omics
data analysis in trying to address key
questions in infectious diseases like
sars like malarial infection like um the
sf9 cells will actually
tell you about how to
identify viral contamination in your
samples and ebola virus apatobic is an
excellent example of how genomics data
was used to track the progression this
disease progression and spread of ebola
virus so when you come down the
application of our mixed data analysis
is at its peak to oncology because of
the requirement and because of how a
mixed data characterizes tumor cancer
and
generally the disease progression and
its effect on various types of patients
and various types of um
yeah
on various types of races and admission
so what we get
part of the reason why it is required
because of the existing traditional
methods of identifying characterizing
understanding the disease progression of
tumor and treating the disease tumor
disease and cancer as such is not
sufficiently effective so hence we had
to research to transcriptomics or
genomics data analysis epigenomics data
analysis and etc so when we have a
wealthy of such information and big data
it is natural that
methods that are specifically designed
to analyze patterns from these large
quantities of data like advanced
statistical methods involving artificial
intelligence deep learning machine
learning will come in handy so they are
also at its most useful when you are
trying to use a large volume of data
like transcriptomics data from major
from lot of patients as compiled in a
wonderful public repository like the
cancer genome atlas or tcga so we also
have a
ncbi database where the sra data will
provide you a lot of genomics
information and genomics data where you
can focus on
for example
genome-wide association studies targeted
loci studies to understand the
specific genes and
driver genes that are
that could be used to
answer and that could be used to explore
the onset disease progression and the
treatment response of different tumor
from different cases
and there are also efforts in
understanding cancer from integrating
multiple or multi-omics
as such from maximizing the information
and also integrating the omics data type
with the wealthy of cancer history
patient history database and
presentation history data and and the
treatment information data and the
genetic data
genetic history data generally that
most of the
translational approaches will acquire at
the time of diagnosis and we are we can
also use traditional methods like using
structural biology and
our mix data
in our mix data integrated into
structural biology for
developing different drug targets and
drug molecules like chemo informatics
data to
to to approach the translational
problems of finding and identifying
targets for
for these cancer research and also
finding and
developing uh
treatment strategies for uh targeting
these specific uh targets that we
identify from structural biology efforts
as i mentioned in the previous case
metagenomics has been is one of the
upcoming area that has been
linked to majority of the onset and
progression of disease from various
other parts of our body and this doesn't
stop but cancer and this doesn't stop at
gut
or
chronic diseases development so again
to give you a few examples of what are
the different projects that we have in
our mix omix learn we have a
project that focuses mainly on the
immune
response of the cancer to different
immune therapies and we have
projects that deals with mass or huge
volume of data from the cancer genome
atlas to identify risk factors that are
associated with liver cancer and we have
we have a project that actually tries to
relate omics data with the treatment
response data that is observed from uh
crafting the tumor into model
environment like mouse model and like
cell line models etc
and that will straight away form and
that will straight away lead us from
understanding oncology through our mix
data analysis into
translational aspects of oncology in
precision medicine through the
application of omics data analysis in
in treating cancer so for this specific
for this specific aspect or for this
specific um research
research topic then we have one project
or we have multiple other
examples with this specific project
modeling cancer precision medicine which
i was talking about where the cancer
cells were grown in a cell line data
cell line in
where they are grown in cell line
environment and they were treated with
multitude of different treatments and
their response to different treatments
through
through the uh
through increase or decrease in the
volume of the tumors are observed and
this response treatment response is
directly linked with multiple omics that
characterizes these
tumor cells and by
linking these omics data type and a
treatment response we can identify which
treatments are effective and how we can
use our mix data types to effectively or
to
accurately identify the effectiveness of
this treatment and this will fall
straight into patient stratification in
terms of which patients are what are the
subset of patients that will respond to
a specific treatment and treatment
strategy
in terms of what are the possible
treatment options that i can suggest to
a
patient who is likely to respond to
several different treatment options and
this doesn't stop at treating hosts from
hosts from
human or from uh
majority uh focus on homo sapiens and
human this also
extends to agriculture where i believe
the
analysis has a lot to offer and the
application has lot to offer in terms of
understanding for example uh drought
resistance understanding for example
salinity resistance understanding for
example heat resistance of crops which
naturally have acquired these
characteristics since they are being
since they are being exposed to these
harsh conditions one can one can
characterize the these plants um
using again these molecular
characterization methods from omics data
types analysis and then try to apply
whether such
whether bringing about such changes in a
different plant can actually result in
developing resistance for drought
developing salinity in the resistance
and also
whether can we transfer the ability of
plants to
survive in harsh condition
by changing the omics
landscape of these plants so such
efforts are actually actively going on
in
in agricultural area and again to stress
on the application of metagenomics data
analysis to a wide variety of biology
and in general people usually take the
soil samples understand the microbiome
population of the soil samples from
different parts right from for example
from
from a region which receives very low
rainfall or from a region which receives
very high rainfall so we can understand
what are the different
bacteria fungi and virus that makes you
use of these conditions and effectively
to help the plants
grow at its maximum
potential
so these are different areas in
agriculture which are actively upcoming
and developing currently
and both in
basic mechanistic research and also in
application oriented research in
agriculture in plant biology
generally
and
neuroscience is also one of the field
where people have tried to understand or
people have tried to apply or mix data
analysis from samples from brain and
there is a practical difficulty in
acquiring samples
from brain from for live patients and
hence now uh there is a lot of effort in
trying to
you'll see we can't hear
okay it seems that he has lost his
connection
making these connections that are
usually not observable using traditional
analysis methods and and
and evaluating uh them for the
statistical
verification or statistical significance
of these connections and transcript
traffic data analysis as i mentioned is
one of the most
used or mixed data analysis or one of
the most
applied omega state analysis to variety
and wide variety of different um
questions related to
human
translational biology and neuroscience
is not
agnostic to that also so traditionally
people take or people extract samples
once the patients have passed away from
the brain cells and compare it with the
healthy patients who are age-matched
gender-matched ethnicity matched so that
we are eliminating lot of other
confounding factors in trying to
understand the
gene expression landscape of
neurological neuro neurological
disorders compared to
healthy patients
so when we extend such analysis to
metabolic disorders like uh like
like allergic reaction to gluten or like
allergic reaction to some specific
metabolome or some uh some people will
have acid reflux so in lot of these
these disorders and and and some people
will have difficulty in in
in filtering salts in sydney so in lot
of these disorders again comics data
analysis is actually proving to be very
helpful because um traditional methods
of observing histological
data are
biochemical assay data is limited in
characterizing the tissue sample tissues
and samples
in what they offer and trying to extract
the genes and trying to extract the gene
expression data trying to extract the
dna from which in the within the cell is
um is actually more helpful in trying to
understand uh or trying to get a
holistic picture of
the samples themselves which can be
useful in
relating to various different
phenotypical applications and
phenotypical characteristics of these
samples that we have categorized like we
can take
samples from healthy patients compared
to samples from who has developed
chronic allergy to for example peanuts
and we can understand uh in what are the
major ways the transcript
transcriptomics landscape differ uh in
uh between these two samples uh
depending on where the samples are from
samples could be from um
from the skin or from the uh from the
stomach lining or from the gut
microbiome also so um so the
various other uh omix data types are
also explored in this um biological
approach
so all biology is is not i mean
all biology is not related or limited to
being applied on earth alone so upcoming
research in space omics where nasa and
other space agencies from all over the
world are heavily
focused on heavily
investing is the application of omix
data analysis for understanding the
effect of space
on human body or on model systems so
people have found out effective method
to
simulate microgravity on modern systems
and microgravity on human cells
themselves so uh people observe or
people characterize these human cells uh
based on the omics data analysis or
molecular characterization that will
take multiple different omics data uh
characterization and then compare it
compare the data compare the
data landscape before and after
subjecting them subjecting the samples
or subjecting the model systems to
microgravity or to a space travel in
terms of uh in terms of astronauts or in
terms of even they took mouse to uh
international space station wants to
perform these analysis so these are the
different
fields that biology and bioinformatics
and omix data big data or mixed data
analysis are actually influencing
actively and
and
very rapidly right i mean space omics is
kind of a field that nobody would have
heard about three years before and right
now uh it's actually picking up on even
a lot of upcoming and developing uh
countries are actually focused on
performing or understanding uh these uh
the effects of
microgravity and space travel on
astronauts and other
subjects
so we have
these yeah we have these different
fields that are being actively explored
on by students
as they have
as they have
um presented you their research topic of
interest so it it depends upon what you
want to
focus on for example you can focus on
cystic fibrosis you can focus on sars go
to characterization using different
analysis method you can focus on
non-long long non-coding rnas for being
targets in leukemia and you can also
focus on different biomass trying to
understand biomarkers for prostate
cancer or cancer types that has not been
studied actively like cervical cancers
prostate cancer and etc so this doesn't
stop at um
at the uh
[Music]
framework or at uh different biological
aspects that we are limiting you to you
can also map
trying to mix match these
analysis methods and different
biological questions that you can answer
from
look or explore this
page and this web
page and web link has lot of information
and
links forwarded for you to
understand the
effect of a research fellowship program
and its reach
through the aspects or through the
dimensions or through the view of
students themselves you can you are free
to check
different submissions from
students and and on the variety of
topics that they were interested in uh
exploring uh omix data analysis and
their applications in general so with
that yeah we also have further more
links to
some of the major or some of the key
talks from compiled from our
previous
webinars and from
symposium that we
successfully conducted at the end of or
the beginning of april rather
um so thank you or just be for playing
the video
so
hello guys uh i'm sparsh and i am
business development associate uh here
at find biotech and now i'll take you
through the registration
part and the resources everything which
you have access to one year
once you enroll in this program so let
me share my screen
oh just could you please confirm if you
can see my screen
yes
thank you so much
so uh this is the program page of
bioinformatics and data science research
fellowship
and
i'll just share the link in the chat box
yes so here you go
now when you scroll down
you will find the program overview that
this research fellowship program has
been specifically designed for young
researchers and students so that they
can take advantage of bioinformatics
resources so as to analyze the complex
big data
and become first in bioinformatics
now
when you'll scroll down
so you will find the proper full
framework of the research fellowship
program which you will go which you
which you will go through
in the duration of your research
fellowship program
so the first like the first thing which
you learn which you learn is about the
introduction introduction to different
courseworks related to bioinformatics
and computational biology different ngs
data types like genomics transcriptomic
method genomics and epigenomics then the
second thing is about the eval
evaluation
so
you'll work on an independent project
topic selection through literature
review
then after once your project
title your research question is selected
you will
practically
apply that
you will practically learn that using
some example research project which we
have on our portal related to different
domains like cancer neurosciences
agriculture biotechnology and infectious
diseases and extract some meaningful
insights from those large data sets
now next is about the comprehension and
analysis
where you'll do some exploratory
analysis
then after that you will work on
investigation
and whatever you have gone through
whatever you have gone through with your
investigation your learning part your
analysis part you will prepare a
scientific report out of it and submit a
project
so this was a brief about the framework
of the research fellowship program
now i if you scroll down you'll find
three different fellowship lens that is
of one is of 45 days another is of 60
days and then is of 90 days
and uh the pricing for 45 days in you
dollars is dollar 350 for 60 days is
totally 450 and for 90 days it's dollar
550.
those who are in different location for
example those who are in africa or
nigeria or in brazil or in india
so they can choose accordingly
uh
they can choose the uh currency
accordingly and the pricing will then
show according to their location
so right now the pricing is usd so it's
reflecting in dollars if you choose
according to your location it will start
reflecting according to your currency
now if i talk about the resources so the
common resources which you have access
which you avail once you enroll in this
program is you will have access to our
omics logic learn portal where there are
multiple coursework example research
project and case studies through which
you will gain conceptual knowledge
you will have access to our t bioinfo
server which is an ai based cloud
pipeline having different toolkits
performing different functionality
then you have access to our coding
sessions
our session recordings online mentor
support through
skype groups online technical support
and certification after the completion
of the
program
now these were the common resources
now what's the difference between the
three is
in 45 days tenure
uh you will be having access to the
common group discussions and the online
mentor support but if you opt for 60
days and 90 days you will have an
opportunity to uh conduct like to have
one-on-one mentor guidance as well
related to your research project your
queries or for future career guidance as
well
now
uh how to proceed with the payment
checkout
for example if you are interested in two
months research fellowship you can click
on buy now
it will redirect you to the omics logic
checkout page if there are any coupon
codes or uh available you can
type like you can paste the coupon code
here
you can add your user details
your country your occupation your
organization and then click on this
checkbook a check box to proceed with
the payment checkout you can pay via
stripe paypal etc
so this was brief about the
registration part
now we have scholarship also
so this is the scholarship form
whosoever
uh like uh there are
they are facing any financial problem or
something so uh they can fill out the
scholarship form and we'll be entering
will be texting or mailing you back here
after reviewing your scholarship form
for further queries you can mail us at
marketing
at the rate omixlogic.com
and
the official number the indian official
number is nine eight
seven six one three four one two zero
and this number is active on whatsapp
also
so uh feel free to reach out to us at
marketing and omixlogic.com for the
queries and now i'll just stop sharing
my screen
and let me know if anyone is having any
doubt or query related to registration
part
thank you
so i guess there are no more questions
and then we are good to go and uh thank
you dr raghavendran
and ojasvi and sanalika and everyone
else
for being
being a part of this webinar
so take care and please uh share your
queries if anyone is having on marketing
at the ricomix retromixlogic.com thank
you